welcome to this video playing r km or a
kr 13 this is a 13 oasis no this is an L
right oh it's difficult okay i'm in a 15
minute game let's see let's see let's
see let's see maybe the curl calm just
mixing up variations okay and 95 chatted
and nope 95 is a pretty interesting
variation check but he didn't go for
that yeah here black shouldn't have any
any problems in in equalizing so it's a
very solid set up I maybe want i play
with nygean keeping the option of f65
open I worked Castle short though I
don't don't really like long castling so
much in those those structures okay so
should I go with F 635 you have the
night only three is not really hmm it's
not really
that's not a common place for the night
not quite sure what he's doing hmm judge
III night therefore i didn't i didn't
really threaten i can i can still set up
this this useful structure maybe i can
still go for the minority attack but
it's nothing that i need to rush
particularly also could put the night on
see form
hmm yeah maybe ok this is this idea to
play f65 is not really very very
probable now we put this on c4
yeah that's comfortable i put the night
on c4 and then it is tricky for him to
capture it as it frees up d 5ki so
probably will do that night c4 we
haven't store should be fine and he
really took them and then I wanted to go
95 yeah that's very comfortable it's not
not easy to improve upon but it's a
super solid the knight on d5 yeah I can
initiate further exchanges we didn't
this is in fact a move that is a bit
weird as I can play a five-night does
not have any squares besides II five and
then that I can just take okay now the
question is do I play it in a positional
manner just increasing pressure on the D
file or f4 f4 is also quite quite good I
believe
not sure I can I can strengthen this
this whole thing though Quincy six fits
into boast both scenarios the f5 f4 idea
we are still the queen is on a good
diagonal and that prepares look the
eight d7 d8 and cover c5 so that Bishop
c5 is not easily being played yeah
should I play a fire that's really
tempting our form oh come on let's let's
do this it gives a useful role to this
rook yeah maybe you can really play G
form
it's not 12
it's still a pretty good move yet when
you form
should I player 3 f three years I guess
I should really this is always a
decision that needs to be um needs to be
considered carefully to place our such a
yeah to play such upon it's um it's very
aggressive yeah it looks very aggressive
and it is in a way but it's also pretty
lonesome piece on f3 so need to be sure
that it is not picked up by some
maneuver but I am the knight on d5 is
always covering III for example so that
it's not quickly or in any way I believe
possible to round the corner and just
take it and my next idea is to play rook
at five maybe h5 gaining more space even
yeah intending h5 or Queen f7 simply
what I must be cautious about it's
rookie five-year this is a tactical
liability as this pawn only six needs to
defend both pieces so if the bishop
moves and then in the near future and
maybe should flick in a move like rock
the aid
yeah age 5 mmm it's not clear that this
really is doing anything great for my
position okay I think I play a normal
strengthening move first covering this
d5 night so that this overload of the e6
bonus is solved Queen f5 and rube d5 so
what is why doing now Bishop age 6 it's
not leading to much
I think I can just take III actually now
isn't this just winning he cannot
recapture as the rook is singing and if
it takes D at queen da droopys fierce
Queen d1 made and yeah this is just just
a piece that's just a piece yeah rook
takes Queen d1 checkmate and two moves
and this check is also quite nice white
resign yeah it's just a just a blunder
yeah what white really should avoid yeah
this this Bishop e3 is a really strange
move something like this is normal and
not this nope yeah so and this idea to
exchange the strong night what he did
with Bishop e3 this is leading to a very
typical and classic piece distribution
of a great night against and
not-so-great bishop and here there are
many good ideas I can also do an
immediate transformation of advantages
and grab the D file that's very nice
also with this idea maybe here here yeah
until this is also good with F form
using the F file and trying to together
and get in a tech out of it yeah f3s
mentioned this is something to be a to b
to be done with knowing what
responsibilities you are you're taking
yeah fortunately he he blundered with
rookie to which immediately gives away
the game um if you place some other move
this is still am still a fight I mean
the computer is actually giving white a
slight edge which I don't really believe
because white has absolutely no idea
here what you should do I mean f3 you
can add attack and I have some ideas in
on the King side
maybe 93 was was even better leading to
a very very pure advantage in a way with
the open D file just under control and
this is a bit murky with the porn on a
three but I like blacks John's anyway
even if the computer gives Y 20.2 would
just not too much anyway alright thanks
for watching